hey everyone my name is kendy a member
of the little light studios team
i'm one of the people you may have
interacted with if you've ever reached
out to us on social media now sometimes
we get a lot of people asking the same
kind of questions so we thought it would
be cool to make these little videos
answering some of them
now a question i get frequently and
actually one that grabs my attention is
is there any hope for me
this question usually comes from someone
who
who thinks they're too far gone
their mind is crowded or or heavily
influenced by by damaging music
hollywood films
gnostic messages and and sometimes
pornographic material
their addictions they seem so so intense
that they can't even conceive a life
without it
i'd like to address that with an
illustration
this cup of water represents the mind
the food coloring
bad media choices
[Music]
what was once clear
is now dull
dark and foggy
and over here we we have some bleach and
baking soda
[Music]
you know god is pretty straightforward
and he's a personal being he says
plainly in isaiah 41 verse 10
do not be dismayed for i am your god i
will strengthen you and help you
and being the gentleman that he is there
is one condition before he steps in
revelation chapter 3 verse 20 tells us
jesus is standing at the door knocking
and deuteronomy chapter 30 verse 19 says
he has laid before us a choice
one of blessings and one of curses and
of course the choice is ours but he
admonishes us to choose life
and what does that choice look like
[Music]
it is possible to be freed from the lies
pervading our thoughts regardless of the
wrong decisions and mistakes god is
wanting to help the helpless overcome
he has the power to create in us a new
mind a new heart and a new spirit
you know he actually continues in isaiah
saying i will uphold you with my right
hand
now we all know that doing the right
thing isn't always easy and sometimes
even after being delivered we may fall
prey to temptation
but guess what
god's forgiveness his righteousness it
covers that
[Music]
stand firm on the promises in the bible
that once you decide to let christ into
your heart he will begin to make a
change in you
whether immediate or with time you'll
notice the change and will be able to
bask in the freedom of god's love
[Music]
we'd love to hear from you leave us a
comment under this video or reach out to
us privately on our instagram page or
facebook
and if you don't use social media that's
all right send us an email through our
website little light studios dot tv
slash contact us
now this is actually the first video in
a new series called i got a question
concise answers to your media related
questions
hey
we're here to help
we're here to help you
let your little light shine
you